[Applause]
all we need are these two facts here and
it's interesting i've looked around and
seen a variety of different answers i'm
going to draw a line that does two
things number one it's always going to
stay positive so it's always going to be
up here okay this is my gradient right
and the other thing it's going to do and
this is the thing i've missed have a
look closely at what you've drawn in red
or equivalent
is your red graph your gradient is it
decreasing because it needs to get
shallower and shallower and shallow
that's what it represents right so when
i put those two together i get something
like this
can you see how that red line or that
red curve i should say it fits both of
my qualities right number one it's
always positive you see it stays up
above right i mean it gets pretty low
but that corresponds to the fact that
this thing gets pretty flat right flat
means low gradient okay
but it's decreasing i noticed a lot of
you did something a bit like this it's
like i think it just kind of follows
right but if it does that and goes up
you're getting steeper and steeper and
stiffer steeper if that's what the
gradient is doing but you all told me
it's getting
shallower and shallower and shallower so
shallower gradient corresponds to a
lower value from my red graph
now we're going to prove this in a
second but i wonder what you think the
equation of that red line is
we're going to prove this d y
on dx equals something you know
something that looks quite familiar so
i'm going to get you to do i don't want
to spoil anyone but because you see what
i think about spoilers i'd love you to
draw an idea anything it doesn't matter
how ridiculous or crazy it is but if you
see this graph what do you think that
looks like is there any graph you know
about
that matches this kind of shape i'll
give you a second to do that i need a
bit more space on the board so i'm going
to wipe this off
underneath here make this subheading
with me proof we're going to go
i mean visuals are cool but they're kind
of like i think this might be what it is
if i really want to know
you've got to start inter you know
interacting with the algebra so that's
what we're about to do now just like we
went and looked at exponentials visually
and then said what can we look at logs
visually i'm going to do the same thing
with the algebra i'm going to start with
the exponentials algebraically and then
we're going to move to the logs okay
so start off with a nice easy result
that you guys all know right if i have
just stock standard exponential function
then its derivative should be what
this is the one we know right shout it
out at me you cannot you all know
e to the x right
okay cool this is the easy bit right now
what i want to do is i want to say well
this is all in exponentials how do i get
this in terms of
logs so the first step is going to be
let's have a look at this right how
would i rewrite this as a log equation
you've been doing this quite a bit right
i'll give you a clue
it starts with the word log what am i
going to write next
have a think
the base sphere is going to come from
the base there right the base becomes
the base so this space e will become
this basic that okay and then what
happens to the other two numbers
they just switch around they just switch
around right this is the whole inverse
idea right so this becomes an x this
becomes a y is that okay with you
so
uh sorry have i done that right no it's
the other way around
this becomes an x this becomes a y the
subject of the equation used to be y
now the subject of the equation is x
okay now we're going to do one more
thing that's a bit unfamiliar over on
this side which is
see how we're trying to like reverse
things around here i'm going to reverse
things around here as well
this is a fraction dy on dx i'm going to
turn it upside down like so dx
on
d y
so i've taken the reciprocal of the left
hand side
what should i do with the right hand
side
i'll just take the reciprocal just like
i did before it's
one over e
to the x okay with that
all right now watch closely in fact for
this part i'm just going to ask you to
put your pens down because blink and you
will miss it okay
[Applause]
this is weird this is x equals log y
the thing i want to understand uh this
color the thing i want to understand is
y equals log x that's the thing i really
want to understand okay so in other
words it's this thing but everything's
switched around okay so in a new color
watch this it won't go away so you can
write down in a second i'm going to
switch all my x's and y's okay
so watch what happens when i go from
here
to here okay blink and you'll miss it
switching my x and y's i'll get
log base e of x equals y this is a whole
new equation these two equations are the
same one dressed up differently but this
one i'm doing something new
i'm going to keep on swapping x's and
y's what do i get over here
dx on d y becomes
d y on dx just done a switch right and
then lastly 1 over not e to the x 1 over
e to y
following so far
can i hold on a second
what does this mean if i do the same
thing i'm now sort of like doing the
same thing but backwards okay
this is going to give me a different
exponential equation not y equals e to
the x but
x equals e to the y see that is
everything swat
does this
look familiar
if x equals e to the y i don't have to
write this as 1 over e to the y i can
just write that as 1 over
x that's what it's equal to
did i say blink and you'll miss it
you know what this graph is
looks a whole lot like this red line
doesn't it at least half of it yeah
usually we would say oh there's this
other branch here over here but if you
wrote down one over x like oh this looks
like the hyperbola right well we just
did better than saying the picture looks
like it
we just proved it
that's the derivative that we've been
searching for okay
strange huh but all we did was we just
looked at an exponential from a reverse
angle and that just gave us logs the
derivative of y equals log x
is 1 over x let's just write that as a
summary
therefore if you've got the derivative
of log base e of x
what's it equal to
one over x
but just be watchful right
it's not all of one over x uh one over x
the whole thing it looks like this
zoop
right we've seen this from last year do
you remember that okay so this is all of
one over x i don't want all of it
which part do i want
yeah just the positive part this part
over here so normally the way we say
remember a couple lessons ago i talked
about domain restrictions so there's a
domain restriction on this you can put
it in like curly braces like this we
would say it's just the positive part
x is greater than zero
and you're done okay
so this result here it just kind of it's
like a new key that unlocks a whole
bunch of doors we've just been looking
at exponentials now but everything with
a log in it we can also work with